uh Bob said okay we got a problem here
you're gonna have to teach this kid how
to talk the way you want to talk and I
thought why don't why don't I just talk
the way he talks right and he had this
he had this hard g at the end of his if
he said it wasn't thinking it was
thinking uh it wasn't making it was
making and says what does uh what does
your father do Micah my my daddy makes
Grace that's what he said and he said he
make he I don't understand his grease
something he met yes he says what do you
do with Greece well Greece goes into all
different sorts of products
I just said we're like what products oh
Greece goes into lipsticks
it's like well I'm not this is it this
is it